over on our sister channel cinemasins
they take a few sins off for classics
right at the beginning because they're
just that [ __ ] good we've never done
that because we're sending single
episodes but this show and episode are
so good that if we don't take off a few
right now we're going to spend the
entire episode in awe of the acting
writing emotion and relevant historical
context to this spectacular show
so we'll return five sins now so we can
start nitpicking the hell out of all the
stuff later that probably doesn't even
matter
i hate circle wipes circle wipes aren't
for shows and movies they're for when
you just had a bad taco bell experience
and don't know where to begin just
remember outside
in front to back you'll be fine how very
convenient that he just happened to
lasso him in front of this church for
maximum story and symbolic effect
reading movie theaters post 2020 this
event actually happened
fair enough cine but considering the
show is actually confronting it head-on
and thematically wrestling with the
depth of racism in america throughout
shouldn't those be sin removals
that's what i thought you might think
i'd send plastic lids for all the time
they've refused to do their job and
deluged our collective laps but this was
clearly the driver's fault for power
squeezing his cup and flipping his lid
probability of drugs and or alcohol in
the subject's vehicle
high probability of firearms and or
explosives
in the vehicle hi
answering telephone customer service
surveys not using bulletproof glass for
all police cars in redford's america
tossing salad without consent
[Music]
this year by oea does not feature a john
mcclane or even a [ __ ]
spelling your state like that makes you
more important looking at you too ohio
also unless i miss the extended farting
solo this is really the worst version of
uncle [ __ ] i've ever heard
minecraft's name would they start to
shut up again
yeah who would have thought violent
racist would violate the unspoken pact
via ordinance that's kept the peace for
three years they're usually so good with
following government mandates convenient
news position of dr manhattan on mars is
convenient
we don't have walls it all comes
tumbling down
but john mellencamp when he was still
rocking the cougar in the middle told me
that the walls themselves come tumbling
down which makes more sense because
without
walls what exactly is there to tumble
down this is a metaphor of lies
what are those kids wowing about so
intensely the show's incredible use of
eggs is a metaphor and story device and
the way these yolks end up looking like
the famous watchmen smiley
i agree it's impressive but how do the
kids know that i
was one of the cops who got attacked on
the white night
and that was before police officers were
allowed to wear masks you see children
career day exposition is the sneakiest
exposition of all because it not only
allows your character to give important
information to the audience
it also does it in a setting where
spelling out the details and
dumbing it down makes complete sense it
smells
like punk your mom just cleaned that
nasty squid off the windshield and you
didn't help because you don't like the
smell
this thing is for your shellfish motives
this article reads that the victims of
vandalism are pictured above however not
pictured pictures
hey that was nice of them to let martin
scorsese add some artwork he made
shortly after the 1980 oscars
boy social media wars are really getting
intense huh arriving after the movie has
already started
it's my funeral surprise main character
death in the first episode shadowing is
my favorite kind of shadowing but it's
still shadowing nonetheless and you
know what we do in the shadows wave
looks like destro and i can literally
see nothing else when i have to look at
him and in a show this good this is what
counts as a sid
it's going to ask you a series of
questions answer them honestly
and you can go home answering in-person
customer service surveys
holy cows they got a [ __ ] plane did
nash bridges and his cavalry not do any
recon before storming the ranch they had
a small cover over it but you can still
tell it's a plane and it's out in the
open
[Applause]
[Music]
where are the others maybe you should
figure that one out before taking your
masks off
is it a special occasion of course it is
master
it's your anniversary even the great
watchman isn't immune from a case of the
man for gets his own anniversary cliche
singing a cappella but not adding a
harmony part that is a horseshoe
mr phillips jeremy's iron would be
excellent at tv since
watching watchmen which is watching a
man watch a man watch a watch which man
mended whilst man wasn't watching me in
watch watch mending
nobody hates oklahoma cornhusker deniers
the clock is ticking ah sudden end of
the episode narration i don't care that
it's narration within a trailer for a
movie that's within the show that's
narrationception
of course he's the kind of jerk that
answers the phone without pausing what's
playing on the television
just be like the rest of us and send
those troglodytes that still make phone
calls to voicemail so we can keep
watching reality television it's called
being polite
also landlines i'm full of confidence
yeah i noticed someone coming out of
your nose at dinner
that's been a tough week look i've seen
this tried as an excuse for snorting
cocaine and i can tell you it rarely
works
like maybe 12 percent of the time just
tell her you picked up some during your
vice beat she'll
totally believe that i'm gonna change
into my uniform changing into your
military dress uniform before getting
killed cliche
having this long of driveway really
feels like it should be a sin what kind
of snollygoster needs this long of a
driveway
and yeah yeah they've got farmland in
the front put all your animals in
the back who do you think you are j.r
ewing now 30 years of bredford and what
have we got to show for it and think of
all this world missed out on
sneakers spy game the horse whisperer
and spy game oh sh i said that one
already well we missed out on sneakers
what i know they were just getting it on
pretty hard and all but cal looks like
he was just dipped in melted butter i
haven't seen muscles this slick since
the fate of the furious
but
you use the name of the episode in a
powerful fashion right before the
credits roll and it completely ties
everything in your episode up in such a
perfect way that even the big twist
becomes more intricate and brilliantly
foreshadowed in hindsight
dang it watchmen even your role
commercials moment is genius and fresh
roll commercials in reverse
all right now get mad at them damn days
there's this proud moment in every
content creator's life when their
creative offspring head out on their own
channel adventures and don't need papa
cinemasins anymore well
that don't you forget we're always
started and get your ass back over to
cinemasins before dark
damn kids can i take a look at your face
you want me to call in red tonight no
let them sleep she gonna be pissed
joylessly masturbating to pictures of
dead deer
the new york times is calling it the
most important television event
it's almost time kids the clock is
ticking
be in front of your tv sets for the
horriton
so roll into nixonville and round them
up and drag their asses into the pod for
interrogation
you burned your last burrito that's a
lot of cows uh